[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de parlement hebdo le
meilleur de la semaine politique et
parlementaire avec vous marion becker
bonjour marion et bonjour aux rien est
notre invité cette semaine et florian
bacheliers bonjour vous êtes député la
république en marche dit les vilaines et
vous êtes également le premier questeur
de l'assemblée nationale merci d'être
avec nous merci au programme de ce
numéro la révision constitutionnelle les
débats à l'assemblée sont ralentis par
les mille trois cent soixante dix huit
amendements déposés les députés
parviendront-ils à tenir le calendrier
cette réforme de la constitution à
l'occasion d'un bras de fer entre
l'opposition et la majorité est
notamment sur le rôle du parlement le
sénat examinait la loi élan loi
controversé qui entend relancer la
construction de logements et l'offre de
logements sociaux
le climat est elle encore tendues entre
le gouvernement et les sénateurs
ils ont déposé mille amendements sur ce
texte fleuve pour redonner du pouvoir
aux mères en matière d'urbanisme
enfin nous ferons le bilan de la session
parlementaire nous reviendrons sur les
textes qui ont marqué cette première
année législative pour les députés et un
tiers des sénateurs et on commence cette
semaine avec la réforme de la
constitution qui s'éternise à
l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est sur la partie constitutionnel de
la réforme des institutions que doivent
se pencher les députés mais les députés
de l'opposition ont lancé la charge sur
la réduction du nombre de parlementaires
et sur l'introduction d'une dose de
proportionnelle qui ne doivent être
examinée qu'à la rentrée mari la bat
quel fonctionnement pour le parlement de
demain c'est la question qui a occupé
les députés cette semaine avec dès le
lundi le vote d'une série d'amendements
identiques sur la possibilité pour le
président de la république d'assister
aux débats après son intervention devant
le congrès si on se retrouve à
versailles c'est que les prises on a
décidé par l'article 18 lui interdit de
rester sous sap parfaitement anormal il
est bien qu'il soit là en direct à
versailles
écouter les parlementaires répondre ou
commenter ou faire des propositions à
son propos ça permet et d'éviter une
rupture encore plus forte entre
l'exécutif et l'initiative les députés
ont aussi décidé de la suppression du
verrou de 120 jours davantage de séances
pourront désormais être programmées
durant les sessions ordinaires
y'a pas un argument fondé pour expliquer
pourquoi on n'a pas une session
ordinaire sur 140 jours aucun argument
fondé nous expliquer c'est pour répondre
à des périodes de crise tendent et en en
session extraordinaire la crise quelle
est-elle aujourd'hui pour réformer la
constitution
la crise allait quoi aller jeu bien
qu'il ya une crise une crise
existentielle du président de la
république tchèque qui veut à tout prix
avoir sa réforme la constitution mais je
vois pas d'autres crises l'amendement
adopté a toutefois été sous amendée pour
permettre la tenue de sessions
extraordinaires
si le premier ministre le juge
nécessaire enfin l'essentiel des
tensions s'est cristallisé autour de la
réduction du nombre de parlementaires
une promesse de campagne d'emmanuel
macron qui inquiète les députés vous
écrivez tout ça avec une emphase une
emphase qui est surprenante alors même
qu'il y a quelques mois les uns et les
autres défendiez des candidats qui
voulait diminuer le nombre de
parlementaires
les françaises et les français vont
mesurer la tartufferie de votre
argumentation
ce volet de la réforme des institutions
n'arrivera pourtant dans l'hémicycle
qu'à l'automne prochain
florian bacheliers on vient de voir les
débats ces tirs votre regard sur la
teneur de ce débat chacun des députés
finalement dépose son amendement veut
intégrer sa propre conception à cette
réforme des institutions avoue le
regretter mais je me dis que les
français qui nous regardent s'il n'était
pas convaincu avant de nous regarder de
la nécessité de réduire le nombre de
parlementaires et de renforcer le
parlement et l'activité l'efficacité du
parlement en regardant les débats des
derniers jours je pense qu'ils sont plus
que convaincu et le président ferrand le
rappelait fort justement c'est une
posture politicienne
en réalité vous aviez benoît mais
françois fillon eux mêmes qu'ils
soutenaient la réduction du nombre de
parlementaires et nous ce qu'on veut
faire c'est justement renforcer le
pouvoir du parlement et qu'il retrouve
sa place dans l'organisation dans
l'institution dans la constitution
pardon de la vème république
et pourtant ce n'est pas ce que disent
les députés de l'opposition et les
sénateurs également qui eux dénoncent un
affaiblissement du parlement avec cette
réforme constitutionnelle oui ceux-là
mêmes qui dans leur programme dans les
programmes des candidats qu'ils
soutenaient disent exactement l'inversé
donc le président ferrand quand il parle
de statut de tartufferie je pense que le
mot n'est pas trop fort vous êtes nous
sommes en train de toucher à un texte
essentiel un texte fondamental c'est un
engagement du président de la république
alors oui ça peut troubler qu'on fasse
ce qu'on a dit mais c'est les français
je crois le voit depuis un an
la ligne directrice qu'on s'est fixés
mais quand vous voyez qu'il y à vous
l'avez rappelé près demi 400 amendements
évidemment ça pose question est ce qu'on
est efficace est-ce que hier une journée
d'obstruction parlementaire
vous savez combien ça coûte une journée
de parlement en france c'est 2 millions
et demi d'euros
pendant ce temps là on n'est pas en
train de s'occuper des vrais problèmes
qui sont que son kiki qui sont vraiment
l'intérêt des français c'est-à-dire
l'école la formation on est en train de
prendre du retard sur des éléments qui
sont essentiels vous appelez un
parlement fort mais dans le même temps
ce texte renforce la mainmise de
l'exécutif sur le parlement sur l'ordre
du jour sur le droit d'amendement
mais pas du tout vous avez trois miss
lyon constitutionnel pour le parlement
c'est faire la loi
contrôler l'exécutif et mesurer les
politiques publiques
aujourd'hui le parlement ne fait pas ça
il travaille beaucoup mais il ne
travaille pas bien et tout le sens de la
révision constitutionnelle de la loi
organique de la loi ordinaire et j'irai
plus loin de la réforme des règlements
en tout cas du règlement de l'assemblée
nationale et tout ce que aussi du côté
de la questure de l'assemblée nationale
toutes les transformations que nous
menons vont dans le sens de d'un
parlement plus moderne plus exemplaire
plus efficace plus rationnelle en termes
de dépenses publiques est au fond un
parlement plus fort aujourd'hui il faut
partir du constat qui est le nôtre
est-ce que tout est ce que vous pensez
que le lien de confiance entre les
français et les parlementaires il est
bon aujourd'hui
est ce que quand on a un taux
d'abstention dernières élections il ya à
peine un an qui est de ce niveau quand
on a une radicalisation des positions
n'avaient l'extrême droite l'extrême
gauche anti européenne et une droite
radicalisée en phase finale d'une
élection présidentielle entre 20 et 25
points 20 le concert ne pas réduire le
nombre de parlementaires va accroître le
lien entre les français déjà c'est faire
ce qu'on a dit on l'a promis c'est un
des engagements du président de la
république et donc moi je crois vraiment
que les français sont attentifs au
respect de la parole publique c'est
aussi comme ça qu'on renouera la
confiance et l'idée c'est d'avoir moins
de parlementaires mais des
parlementaires plus fort et donc tout le
sens des réformes qu'on mène c'est
justement leur donner les moyens
d'exercer leurs missions
quand on parle d'évaluation des
politiques publiques on est en train de
mettre en place justement les outils
pour exercer ses missions aujourd'hui
ces missions ne sont pas des adversaires
les relations se sont attendues à sept
derniers jours entre la droite
sénatoriale gérard larcher et le
gouvernement est ce que vous pensez
qu'un accord est possible encore entre
le sénat et le gouvernement sur ce sujet
moi je pense que le président larcher
est un parlementaire expérimenté il
était élu en 85
de mémoire il connaît bien
le la maison senna je pense qu'il n'y a
aucun intérêt à revenir sur la parole
qui avaient été donnés lui aussi été
chef de file a soutenu
suivant les semaines monsieur fillon
mais en tout cas il a soutenu jusqu'au
bout la droite les républicains et donc
je ne vois pas comment il pourrait
aujourd'hui se parjurer en quelque sorte
à ne pas trouver un accord donc moi je
pense que nous trouverons nous
trouverons un accord dans les prochaines
semaines elle le sait n'a justement se
pencher lui cette semaine sur la loi est
lent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la loi est lent pour évolution du
logement de l'aménagement et du
numérique elle était donc à l'ordre du
jour du sénat en examen attendue pour
cette loi controversée marie brémaud
avant même le début des débats en séance
autour du projet de loi est lent le
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
a tenté de rassurer les sénateurs comme
je les ai déjà dit à vos collègues
députés il serait malvenu de ma part de
contester la procédure parlementaire et
plus encore le droit d'amendement
car les sénateurs ne cachent plus leur
exaspération face à ce qu'ils
considèrent comme de la désinvolture de
la part du gouvernement qui texte après
texte a pris pour habitude d'ignorer
leur travail projet de loi après projet
de loi nous ne pouvons que constater
l'absence d'intérêt du gouvernement aux
propositions et aux apports du sénat que
ce soit en commission en séance publique
les élus de tous bords dénonce les
méthodes employées par l'exécutif dans
l'élaboration de la loi
les amendements de suppression juste
avant l'examen du texte ou encore les
nouvelles dispositions envoyé dans la
nuit
1.2 quasi-rupture gérard larcher a
d'ailleurs adressé un courrier au
premier ministre cette semaine afin que
la voix du sénat soit respecté mais pour
autant dans l'hémicycle l'exaspération
n'est pas retombée loin de la tâche et
monsieur le ministre que ce qui est en
train de faire le gouvernement
c'est un mépris du parlement par ce
mépris nous vous répondrons par notre
travail par l'intelligence de nos débats
pour faire la démonstration que le sénat
une utilité dans ce pays des invectives
répéter auquel le premier ministre a
finalement répondu lors des questions au
gouvernement
l'objectif c'est donc de faire en sorte
que le débat puisse être plein et entier
que nous puissions lorsque nous ne
sommes pas d'accord pointer ces
différences les admettre les documenter
et faire en sorte que
par le jeu du bicamérisme et de la
navette parlementaire on puisse aboutir
à la fin aux meilleurs textes possibles
c'était tentative d'apaisement
maladroite et peu concluante la tempête
institutionnel qui gronde au sénat n'est
pas prête de passer là bas chez lui on a
vu un des tensions sur la méthode c'est
l'organisation du travail parlementaire
et at il comme le disent certains
sénateurs à mes prix du parlement mais
moi j'entends une nécessité de
transformer justement le parlement pour
qu'on ait les conditions de travail qui
permettent d'être plus efficace a
rejoint le point un précédent sur la loi
landes
l'exemple typique les sénateurs ne
disent pas la même chose dans
l'hémicycle que à l'intérieur de
l'hémicycle qu'à l'extérieur de
l'hémicycle
la réalité elle est assez simple là
aussi il faut partir des constats on a 4
millions de mal logés en france
est ce que vous savez alors les
questeurs aime bien les chiffres combien
de budget sur le logement on met par
jour 136 millions d'euros donc c'est ça
ne veut pas dire que c'est trop d'argent
mais ça veut dire que c'est de l'argent
qui n'est pas efficace qui ne qui ne
fonctionne pas on ne peut pas avoir 136
millions d'argent millions d'euros par
don d'argent public dépensés sur le
logement avec un résultat aussi aussi
mauvais pour être très clair 4 millions
de mal-logés c'est juste intolérables et
donc tout le travail de julien de
normandie et jacques mézard c'est
justement retrouver les souplesses qui
permettent de reconstruire
on a trois millions de logements vides
également donc c'est tout le sujet c'est
on peut faire le lien aussi avec le
numérique le le le
on parle de déconnexion de territoires
souvent mais le numérique je viens de
normandie a trouvé un accord avec les
opérateurs télécoms du prêt de 4
milliards d'euros supportés par les
opérateurs télécoms pour raccrocher pour
rattraper les 11 millions de français
qui sont aujourd'hui exclues du
numérique donc moi quand j'entends ces
postures j'ai plutôt pour le coup ça me
fait penser plutôt à justement la
déconnexion des sénateurs par rapport à
entendu au début de la discussion
générale le sénat la rapporteure du
texte dominique estrosi sassone était
d'accord avec vous sur le constant
disant votre diagnostic était le monde
mais elles disent parce que ce texte ne
répond pas ça fait très longtemps au
lycée félix a fait 30 ans que tout le
monde est d'accord sur le diagnostic
mais elle dit que ce texte ne répond pas
à la problématique elle part de
valse-hésitation constante est ce que
c'est le cas ce n'est pas le cas ça fait
trente trois décennies vous savez moi
j'ai 39 ans
ça fait trois décennies que j'entends ça
le on est tous d'accord sur le
diagnostic c'est intolérable etc
on va pas refaire la même chose on va
pas heureux réemployer les mêmes
solutions qui n'ont pas fonctionné
donc on fait autrement et on va aussi la
tenir nos engagements
que ça plaise ou ne s'apaisent pas là le
sujet il ya aussi j'entends une posture
un positionnement des républicains sur
le sujet au fond pourquoi parce qu'il
n'y a pas de contre proposition vous les
entendez vous les contre propositions de
laurent wauquiez au delà de la majorité
les républicains au sénat
vous qui aimez les chiffres le
gouvernement prévoit 40 mille ventes de
logements sociaux contre 8000
aujourd'hui est ce que c'est vraiment
atteignable vous êtes optimiste
non on est déterminés là encore une fois
c'est ne pas juste faire des diagnostics
et sans référence au précédent métier du
du du président larcher
c'est pas juste établir des diagnostics
c'est prescrire et soigner et faire
autrement et aussi prendre le sujet en
amont aujourd'hui je vais vous redire 4
millions de mal logés en france c'est
intolérable donc je n'ai pas de doute
sur le fait qu'à la fin le parlement et
le gouvernement trouveront un accord sur
cette ligne directrice et c'est
l'intérêt général c'est l'intérêt tous
les freins moi juste sur un point du
texte qui a fait des bas rhin 10 % de
logements accessibles aux handicapés
c'est ce que prévoit la loi les
sénateurs ont voté 30% est-ce que c'est
ainsi vous pouvez retenir non mais là
c'est un problème de curseur technique
le sujet n'est pas l'âme le sujet c'est
d'envoyer un signal pour dire qu on
assouplit les conditions
c'est comme pour les pylônes justement
jusqu'à l'épisode télécom dont on
parlait tout à l'heure
jusqu'ici il y avait un visa impératifs
des architectes de france n'a plus
aujourd'hui ça ça permet d'assouplir les
conditions et quand vous écoutez tous
les professionnels ils vous disent
justement que le 100% avant était
inapplicable et provoqué une
augmentation des prix donc ce qu'on fait
on assume ces autrement 6 et 10 6 et 15
je ne sais pas le dire mais en tout cas
on envoie un signal fort pour assouplir
les choses allaient la session
parlementaire s'achève un moment dans
quelques jours c'est donc l'heure de
faire le bilan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une première année du quinquennat a
chargé en réformes que le parlement
examine et amendé voter rejeter des
textes enchaîné parfois à un rythme
soutenu entraînant des critiques de
certains parlementaires sur
l'organisation du travail parlementaire
mari la bat nous dresse le bilan de
cette première année de l'ère macron 52
c'est le nombre de textes de loi que le
parlement a définitivement adopté au
cours de cette session ordinaire
dès le mois d'octobre députés et
sénateurs démarre sur les chapeaux de
roue avec l'examen du sensible texte de
lutte contre le terrorisme
oui nous allons protéger les français
puis c'est le tour du premier projet de
loi de finances plf qui prévoit la
disparition de l'impôt de solidarité sur
la fortune isf au profit de l'ifi
l'impôt sur la fortune immobilière
nous allons libérer plus de 3 milliards
d'euros qui effectivement nous le
pensons iron va l'économie productive
nous faisons le choix de la liberté
nous faisons le choix de la confiance
nous faisons le choix du nouveau monde
fiscale et je pense que cela se traduira
demain par plus de croissance et plus
d'emploi l'oat travail lutte contre les
violences sexistes les parlementaires
enchaîne les textes quitte parfois à
devoir passer par une commission mixte
paritaire
comme pour le polémique pacte
ferroviaire par exemple chacun dans
l'intérêt général a réussi a justement
s'extirper de posture pour essayer
d'arriver à un équilibre qui est très
attendu on sait que que ce soit les
cheminots mais aussi les usagers
tout le monde a besoin qu'on arrive à un
point pour pouvoir avancer
nous sommes satisfaits du résultat qui
est un résultat qui montre que la
construction quand chacun s'y met ça
marche
cette session ordinaire est aussi celle
qui va révéler les premières fracture au
sein du groupe majoritaire lors de
l'examen du projet de loi asile et
immigration notamment à florian
bacheliers vous l'avez entendu certains
regrettent des débats trop expéditif
les débats ont-ils pu se tenir
suffisamment correctement à l'assemblée
au sénat cette année mais ceux qui
disent ça sont ceux qui pendant trois
décennies ont pas pris leurs
responsabilités je vais le dire aussi
franchement j'aime les chiffres je vais
vous en donner un autre c'est 9 millions
de français qui sont assignés à être en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté
programmé ça justifie l'urgence car on
ne fera pas ça justifie l'urgence
justement de d'accélérer les chantiers
et moi je peux vous dire sur le terrain
en bretagne le le cadencement justement
des réformes est apprécié la sncf le
dédoublement des classes ça n'était pas
possible on pouvait pas le faire à la
rentrée mais on l'a fait les ordonnances
travail
on aurait tous les français dans la rue
on pouvait pas assouplir le droit du
travail en france bah c'est pas vrai on
l'a fait le l'image de la france à
l'étranger auprès des investisseurs
étrangers
elle est revenue elle est revenue bonne
la réforme de la sncf qui est elle
évoquée dans le sujet ça n'était pas
possible donc par un député en burn out
pas du tout non non je suis un député
qui est plus que déterminé comme
l'ensemble de mes collègues de la
majorité vous savez on a été élu quand
même à un moment particulier le scénario
qu'on nous proposait depuis deux ans
avant que emmanuel macron s'engage
c'était un scénario d'opposition entre
l'extrême droite et la droite extrême
on porte une responsabilité particulière
à un moment très particulier où vous
sentez les crispations du monde autour
d'eux que ce soit au niveau européen au
niveau mondial et donc on s'est engagé
pleinement en sachant très bien que si
on ne produit pas des résultats sur le
chômage de masse notamment chez les
jeunes générations sur la place de
l'école de la formation au coeur du
dispositif républicains sur la lutte
contre les inégalités mais la lutte pas
en discours en actes si on ne produit
pas des résultats sur la loi sur le
retour de la confiance et le le le
le lien entre les citoyens et les
représentants si on ne retire pas la
confiance si on ne produit pas des
résultats d'ici 2022 on portera une
responsabilité qui est quand même
exceptionnel
on sait ce qui nous attend si jamais on
n'y est pas donc on sera au rendez vous
et ça veut dire ton boss oui 18 19
heures par jour mais on continuera à le
faire le temps qu'on puisse appliquer
l'ensemble des sujets que les français
attendent on a vu des tensions entre les
deux chambres du parlement la plupart
des commissions mixtes paritaires n'ont
pas abouti est ce qu'à une volonté de la
majorité présidentielle de nier le sénat
pas du tout il ya moi je vois de
l'émulation fraternelles entre les entre
les deux chambres parlementaires
après vous avez deux compositions
d'assemblée qui sont différentes
vous avez vu qu'il ya un renouvellement
fort à l'assemblée nationale il ya
beaucoup plus de jeunes beaucoup plus de
diversité de parcours beaucoup plus de
femmes et au fonds beaucoup plus de deux
personnes qui n'ont pas fait pour la
politique un métier
voilà qui tous pas professionnels de la
politique et ça donne une liberté parce
que ça veut dire que on est là aussi
pour le mandat au service de l'intérêt
général et que la fin du mandat en 2022
c'est pas un drame et on a une
composition du sénat qui est pas tout à
fait la même et je crains beaucoup plus
conservatrice et je crains que du coup
il y ait sur l'ensemble des sujets qu'on
ait évoqué tout à l'heure beaucoup
beaucoup de posture
allez il est temps à présent de
retrouver notre partenaire du figaro.fr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à charles sapin bonjour vous nous avez
rejoint pour ces questions politiques
oui tout à fait bonjour michel député
une première question est ce que vous
êtes habilités à faire la police non pas
plus que vous et je peux je ne suis pas
non plus habilité à être magistrat pas
plus que vous très bien donc si je
comprends bien en tant que citoyen vous
n'êtes pas autorisé à faire appliquer
les lois à maintenir à participer à des
opérations de maintien de l'ordre a
procédé à des arrestations mais on est
bien d'accord sinon nous ne serions pas
dans un état de droit je vais vous dire
dans ma précédente vie j'étais avocat
donc auxiliaires de justice
je vais reprendre ma casquette deux
minutes ma casquette d'avant s'il ya une
chose que je sais c'est que le seul
endroit où on peut accomplir l'action de
justice et dans un tribunal le plus
mauvais endroit c'est sur un plateau de
télé c'est sur les réseaux sociaux et
c'est dans un parlement très bien c'est
noté et il ne s'agit pas ici de faire
une action de justice de condamner ni
qui que ce soit d'ailleurs la
présomption d'innocence existe et on la
rappelle pour tous cependant pour
rappeler un petit peu les faits mercredi
soir le monde identifiés dans une vidéo
le chef adjoint de cabinet d' emmanuel
macron le président de la république
grimés en policiers en train de molester
deux étudiants participant à des
manifestations le 1er mai est ce que
c'est quelque chose qui pour vous rendre
dans un état d'âme encore une fois je
vais pas c'est pas pour faire de la
langue de bois mais c'est un principe
fondamental auquel moi je crois et je
pense que ça tient la république donc
c'est extrêmement important
moi je vais pas commenter un fait divers
c'est un fait divers les images elles
sont choquants tellement choquée moi
aussi mais je connais pas l'ensemble du
dossier l'ensemble de la chaîne de
commandement donc je ne sais pas ce qui
s'est passé pas plus que je joue et donc
je fais confiance moi en la justice de
mon pays il ya eu hier une saisine par
le parquet pour accomplir sa mission est
donnée rendre des comptes
l'ensemble des citoyens judaïsme n'est
pas au delà du simple fait divers vous
parler de faits divers ça ma joie quand
même je crois pas
c'est encore une fois vous ne pouvez
jamais juger un dossier sur des éléments
factuels sur des éléments de cette
dimension vous avez un extrait vidéo qui
est choquant personne ne dira à
l'inversé inacceptable la loi est très
claire en tant que vous n'avez pas
pourrez commenter très bien c'est ne
voulait pas commander toute la globalité
des faits puisqu'on ne connaît pas la
même ligne de la déclaration de bruno
roger pg la mélamine sur l'ortf à rendre
le l'elysée j'ai la même ligne sur
l'ensemble des représentants politiques
vous savez ces jeux c'est vraiment hors
coloration politique j'ai la même ligne
pour eric woerth
j'ai la même ligne pour marine le pen
n'a rien à voir ne mélangeons pas tout
si quelqu'un est pris la main dans le
pot de confiture civile et si je fais le
tour du cateau maintenant janvier aux
mains avec vous devant témoins avec des
caméras
évidemment qu'il n'y aura pas besoin d'
enquête pour voir où elle tort et que
j'ai et que mon comportement
irrépréhensible a tant que député
représentant de la nation mais c'est
pour suggérer c'est à dire que j'ai si
oui mais c'est la réponse ne vous
satisfait pas mais c'est la mienne j'ai
11 ans d'expérience pardonnez-moi 11 ans
d'expérience auxiliaires de justice
je suis totalement d accord excuses
alors hier justement le débat s'est
invité que ce soit à l'assemblée
nationale ou au sénat
on va tout de suite écouter edouard
philippe edouard philippe qui étaient
interpellés lors des questions au
gouvernement dans l'hémicycle du sénat
écoutait le premier ministre la sphère
elle est désormais aux mains de la
justice
et c'est très bien ainsi elle est
désarmée
elle est désormais aux mains de la
justice
et c'est très bien ainsi un certain
nombre un certain nombre de questions ne
manqueront pas d'être posée
je souhaite nous souhaitons tous que
cette enquête permette de déterminer les
faits précis les raisons claires
l'enchaînement des décisions qui ont été
prises sur ce sujet je vous remercie
oui très bien donc on vient d'entendre
le premier ministre s'est exprimé hier
au sénat il n'y a pas qu'au sénat on a
parlé beaucoup de cette affaire hier
vous étiez à l'assemblée nationale les
débats ont été phagocyté par cette
affaire benalla alors que les députés
discutent et je vous écoute et tout à
l'heure vous me disiez vous discutiez de
la possibilité en fait de revaloriser le
parlement dans ses fonctions notamment
de contrôle d'évaluation alors même que
tous les bancs de l'opposition appelé
justement edouard philippe le premier
ministe à venir s'exprimer sur cette
affaire il a refusé ce que vous trouvez
pas ça paradoxal
ce que je trouve paradoxal c'est que les
oppositions ont invoqué la séparation
des pouvoirs
montesquieu l'esprit dès lors d'esprit
des lois de l'esprit des lois exactement
et on aurait voulu et on voudrait ce que
les oppositions demandé au fond que le
parlement français se transforme en
autorité judiciaire on est en confusion
totale des rôles de chacun et ça c'est
un danger et ça c'est garanti vous savez
pas quel texte
le texte qu'on est en train de réviser
la constitution donc c'est à dire que la
commission d'enquêté parlementaire qui a
été validée qui a été approuvé par
l'assemblée nationale pour vous ce n'est
pas une bonne chose
moi je pense que seule l'autorité
judiciaire peut faire justice et c'est
les procédures qui sont en cours on en
parlait tout à l'heure donc je laisse le
chemin la justice savait encore une fois
la justice est suffisamment complexe et
suffisamment essentiel pour le laisser
entre les mains de professionnels du
sujet
qui vont analyser décortiquer rendre
compte et prononcer des sanctions en cas
de chute une commission sera pas utile
selon vous c'est en gros une façon de
débloquer une obstruction d'une journée
par des oppositions
ça démontre aussi quand même la vacuité
des oppositions à pardonnez moi de vous
le dire mais quand on passe une après
midi jeux vous redonner le chiffre de
deux millions et demi par jour le coût
du parlement la démocratie n'a pas de
prix mais elle a un coût c'est deux
millions et demi par jour à faire ça
alors que chacun est persuadé en dehors
de l'hémicycle que c'est un fait divers
en réalité que tout le monde a bien
conscience qu'on est en train de
politiser un fait divers mais je crois
qu'on n'est pas à la hauteur des enjeux
et je crois surtout qu'on n'est pas à la
hauteur des ambitions qui sont les
nôtres et des attentes des français
voudraient les français je crois en tout
cas ce que je croise mois les bretons
pas que les bretons mais des français
ils attendent de nous concrètement
encore une fois du concret sur le
chômage sur l'école sur la formation sur
la santé etc et un peu d'essence hérité
aussi mais l'exemplarité justement c'est
ce qu'ont produit nous concrètement mais
là vous me dites produire de
l'exemplarité et mais c'est le le texte
la loi confiance c'est ce qu'on est en
train de faire nous toutes les actions
transparent cet exemple sur juste sur
sur l'assemblée nationale là je reprends
ma casquette de questeur quand on aligne
sur le droit commun le régime de
retraite des députés qu'on se
l'appliquent à nous-mêmes 1er janvier
dernier
ça c'est l'exemplarité et ça sera le mot
de la fin merci à vous merci ou florian
bacheliers d'avoir participé à ce
dernier numéro de la saison de parlement
hebdo
merci à vous chers sapin merci au
rayonnement de chignons et nous vous
disons de rocker à la rentrée prochaine
pour une nouvelle saison de parlement
hebdo très bel été à tous
[Musique]